à l'elysée cet après midi devant plus de
mille journalistes le président de la
république a tenu la 12e et dernière
référence de presse du septennat
il a répondu à diverses questions de nos
confrères français et étrangers groupant
ses réponses par grands chapitres le
chef de l'état traitait tout d'abord du
redressement économique français oui
dans les années qui viennent on va voir
la france bon rang dans le peloton
mondial de tête ont ce qui concerne le
personnel et les moyens d' inventions
d'expérimentation d'application on va
l'avoir activer la construction de ces
autoroutes chi exceptionnellement bon et
nombreuses que soient ses routes
secondaires et on va l'avoir développé
son réseau téléphonique
on va l'avoir mettre ces collèges lycées
institut technique au même plan que les
classiques comme il convient un pays qui
veut avoir à tous les étages de son
activité des cadres multiples et
qualifiés puis répondant à des questions
relatives à la crise du marché commun le
président de la république déclare
notamment
naturellement il est concevable et il
est désirable que la grande entreprise
de la communauté économique européenne
puisse être remise
un jour en chantier mais avant que cela
n'arrive il se passera un délai dont nul
ne peut prévoir la durée car personne ne
sait si caen comment la politique de
chacun de nos partenaires
compte tenu d'ailleurs de certaines
conjoncture électorale ou parlementaire
si cette politique
pourra définitivement s'adapter aux
nécessités telles qu'elles viennent
d'être démontrée quoi qu'il en soit la
france pour sa part est prête à
participer à tout échange de vues qui
seraient proposés par les gouvernements
et le cas échéant elle envisage de
reprendre la négociation de bruxelles
dès lors que l'entrée de l'agriculture
dans le marché commun serait réellement
adopté et qu'on voudrait en finir avec
les prétentions que des mythes abusif
oppose au bon sens et à la réalité
voilà pour le marché comme c'est ensuite
la réponse à un groupe de questions
concernant la politique française
vis-à-vis de l'europe et vis-à-vis du
monde ce dont il s'agit pour nous c'est
de nous tenir en dehors de toute
inféodation c'est ainsi qu aussi
longtemps que nous jugerons nécessaire
la solidarité des peuples occidentaux
pour la défense éventuelle de l'europe
nous resterons des alliés de nos alliés
mais qu'à l'expiration des engagements
que nous avons pris jadis c'est à dire
au plus tard en 1969 cessera pour ce qui
nous concerne la subordination qualifié
d' intégration qui est prévu par l'otan
et qui remet notre destin entre les
mains étrangères
c'est ainsi qu'avec l'allemagne malgré
toutes les blessures subies et tous les
griefs accumulés
nous avons conclu un traité qui sans
doute en un domaine reste à l'état de
cordiale virtualité mais qui cependant
organise la réunion périodique de nos
gouvernements et fructifie dans certains
domaines comme la culture ou les
réunions de jeunesse et cetera
c'est dans des conditions très
différentes mais c'est dans une
inspiration un lob que nous croyons qu
en asie la fin des combats en cours
et puis le développement satisfaisant
des peuples ne pourront être obtenue que
par les relations à établir les
négociations à ouvrir et un modus
vivendi a réalisé entre les puissances
qui depuis a guerres mondiales ont
engagé leur responsabilité directe ou
indirecte dans les événements du sud-est
de ce continent c'est à dire la chine la
france l'amérique la russie et
l'angleterre et nous croyons également
plus fermement que jamais que la
condition élémentaire d'un tel
rapprochement et peut-être d'une telle
entente
ce serait la fin effective de toute
intervention étrangère et par conséquent
la neutralisation complète et contrôlée
de la zone où l'on se bat
c'est à quoi d'ailleurs la france avait
souscrit pour sa part en 1954
enfin le général de gaulle en vient à
parler du septennat par rapport au
régime
eh bien le régime que le pays s'est
donné à 7 ans et auquel ou de la prévoir
qu'il se tiendra désormais ce régime
c'est celui de la majorité nationale
je veux dire de celles qui se dégage de
la nation tout entière indivisible dans
sa masse indivisible et souveraine
ce que la constitution nouvelle comporte
de complètement nouveau et de capital
c'est l'avènement du peuple en tant que
tel et collectivement comme la source du
pouvoir du chef de l'état et le cas
échéant comme le recours direct de celui
ci
et d'autre part l'attribution au
président qui est qui et seul leur
représentant et le mandataire de
l'ensemble de la nation du devoir d'en
tracer la conduite dans les domaines
essentiels et des moyens de sont
acquittés c'est en vertu de cette double
institutions et parce qu'elle a
pleinement fonctionné que depuis sept
ans le régime s'est vu doter de la
stabilité de l'autorité l'efficacité qui
l'ont mis en mesure de résoudre des
problèmes avec lesquels la france
étaient confrontés qu'ils étaient des
problèmes graves et de mener ses
affaires de telle sorte que sa situation
soit meilleure et plus solide qui r on a
parlé de pouvoir personnel
si on entend par là que le chef de
l'état a pris personnellement les
décisions qui lui incombait de prendre
soleil tout cas c'est exact et
d'ailleurs dans quel poste grand petit
celui qui responsable at il le droit de
se dérober
la lionne qui a jamais cru que le
général de gaulle et en appeler à la
barre devrait se contenter d'inaugurer
les chrysanthèmes
par exemple lorsque le problème algérien
préoccupait c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire la nation toute entière à qui
attribuer et ont acquis d'autres
attributs et on est d'une seule voix la
tâche de le résoudre
mais si l'on veut dire que le président
de la république se tenait isolé de tout
et de touche et que pour agir il
n'écoutait que lui-même alors on
méconnaît l'évidence au cours du
septennat et jusqu'à présent le chef de
l'état a réuni 300 deux fois le conseil
des ministes 420 x des conseils
interministériels restreint il a reçu
dans son bureau 605 fois le premier
ministre
78 fois les présidents des assemblées au
moins deux mille fois l'un ou l'autre
des membres du gouvernement
plus de 100 fois les présidents ou les
rapporteurs des commissions
parlementaires ou les présidents de
groupe est à peu près 15 cents fois les
principaux fonctionnaires experts et
syndicaliste et pour ce qui était des
affaires étrangères quelques 600 heures
de conversation avec les chefs d'état ou
de gouvernement étranger et un millier
d'entretiens avec leurs ministres ou
leurs ambassadeurs ont largement
contribué à l'information du chef de
l'état
mais il est vrai que c'est avant tout
avec le peuple lui même que le président
de la république qui en est le
mandataire et le guide s'est tenue se
tient et doit se tenir en contact direct
c'est ainsi en effet que la nation peut
connaître en personne l'homme qui est à
sa tête discerner les liens qui
l'attachent pas lui être au fait de ses
idées de ses actes ses soucis ses
projets de ses espoirs
et c'est ainsi aussi que le chef de
l'état à l'occasion de montrer à tous
les français quelle que soit leur région
ou leur catégorie qui sont tous au même
titre les citoyens d'un seul et même
pays qu'il a l'occasion de connaître en
allant sur place où en sont les âmes et
les choses et d'éprouver au milieu de
ses compatriotes à quoi l'obligent leurs
encouragements
je ne crois pas que depuis sept ans de
tels contacts est été négligé je dirais
même que jamais ils n'ont été multipliés
à ce point trentels locution adressé au
pays tout entier par la voix de la radio
et de la télévision
douze conférences de presse
intégralement diffusés ainsi que 36
discours prononcer solennellement dans
des cérémonies publiques chéri de voyage
accompli indépendamment de plus de 200
apparition officielle à paris accompli
dans les 94 département de la métropole
et l'outre-mer au cours desquelles
le chef de l'état a vu de ses yeux que
15 millions de français
invitéà a conféré avec lui tous les
membres du parlement
tous les corps constitués tous les
conseillers généraux tous les maires de
france visitées à peu près de 1500
communes parmi lesquelles toutes les
principales répondu dans les hôtels de
ville à la bienvenue de environ 400
conseillers municipaux et 200000 notable
parler depuis des estrades 600 fois à la
population a semblé dialoguer avec un
nombre de personnes qu'on ne peut pas
compter serre et d'innombrables mains la
perfection n'est pas de ce monde mais
par rapport à ce qu'il était hier l'état
français montrent maintenant une
solidité et une capacité qui sont
incontestables d'ailleurs nul ne s'y
trompe dans l'univers avant trois mois
le peuple français dira par ses
suffrages s'il entend revenir aux
pratiques du passé ou s'il veut que le
régime nouveau continue d'assurer demain
comme aujourd'hui la conduite de la vie
nationale cartel sera bien tout le monde
le sent et le sait tel sera bien la
signification est le résultat de
l'élection présidentielle
mesdames messieurs je vous remercie et
joueurs de l'usc